who makes your outfit
i can't figure it out got two guesses
no sh kim kardashian totally just
trolled her famous mommager and it's
probably the funniest thing you'll see
all day it's never a dull moment
on sunday the mom of four posted this
clip of kris
jenner rocking head-to-toe christian
dior
yeah that's the brand's recognizable
logo
literally all over it i love that
and kim well she totally lovingly mocked
her mama's look
oh she was on the couch i was taught to
not do that
not in this household i definitely
mom not the dab i'm so curious as to
really who makes this
and if you listen closely you can hear
what sounds like kim's little sister
kylie jenner
channeling her inner mortified teen
telling chris
that the dab is like so out mom
not the dab kim and her fam were
together to celebrate their good friend
jonathan chebin's birthday the kkw
beauty founder rang in the occasion with
a proper post on her
insta story and a little cake
oh that's gonna be getting smacked in
the face by courtney
you really came up with a good one
that cake does in fact read you're
shoved so far
up kim's yeah and if that sounds
familiar
it's because it's from this hilarious
moment in 2013
on courtney and kim take miami you are
shoved
so far up kim's you are delusional
you're a psycho and you're a
[ __ ] why don't you leave don't you have
your own place god's never gonna marry
you
of course the celebration comes just a
few days after kim
officially filed for divorce after
months of speculation about her marriage
to kanye west
you just gotta roll with it a source
previously told et
quote kim's family supports her 100
and has had her back throughout this
whole process
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
the source also noted that the reality
star has been spending more time with
her family
leaning on them and getting advice from
them quote at the end of the day
they all want what's best for kim and
know that this
is the right decision for her and her
[Music]
family